Similes.
Similes compare one thing to another using the words "like" or "as."
For example, if we say, "My aunt is as busy as a bee",...
...we're not really saying that my aunt is a bee.
However, we're comparing how busy she is to how busy bees are.
My brother ran as fast as lightning to catch the bus.
Here, we're comparing my brother's running...
...and saying that it is fast as lightning.
Her eyes sparkled like diamonds when she saw her new toy.
In this example, we're comparing the excitement in her eyes...
...over her new toy to the sparkling of diamonds.
The cookies were as hard as a rock.
Here, we're comparing how hard the cookies were to the hardness of a rock.
Writers and authors use similes...
...to make their writing more descriptive, vivid, interesting and fun.